I've been telling people that I have the
number one song in the world
which is crazy it's my really my first
uh
my first uh
kind of stab at making making real music
uh
nah yeah I know a lot of you guys are
probably wondering me about want to hear
me talk about the [__] Eminem Logic
song but I should say logic Eminem songs
logic featuring Eminem but
yeah man
I [__] they called me uh a week ago
before before the uh
like maybe a five days before the the
song came out
and my manager was like look
D you know I remember in logic and I was
like yeah and he was like okay so Eminem
and him are doing a song
and you know look they're gonna Eminem
put yours your impression of him okay
at the end of the song and it looks like
great so like he wants to know if they
can use it and I was like
are you [__] kidding me and he was
like yeah I'm gonna say yes but like
I'm gonna protect you just can Okay and
like like I'm trying to get you my by
the way I don't know how much is gonna
be but and I was like dude no don't ask
for money just give it to him I don't
care I'm not a rapper let him use it on
the song it's comedy fine
so uh
you know
and then and then I [__] put it and
then I put it on and then they put it on
it came out and it's just like
I'll tell you one thing man look you do
all these things as a comedian or you
know whatever industry you're in you
know as an actor as a comedian as a in
the entertainment World whatever the
[__] you want to say like
all this stuff you reach your you know
you reach goals as they go on and you
know I've been wanting to do specials I
do specials bam you know my first
special came out that was uh uh uh a
mark in my career that was like amazing
for me uh you know those are the things
that even though their goals you ex you
you you expect them in a way because you
you have confidence about yourself in
your career you're like I'm gonna do a
special one day it happens you're like
well I can't believe I'm doing this but
you also you knew that this was the goal
this kind of stuff is always like really
special because you don't know that it's
gonna happen you know you always thought
oh cool
I'm a comedian but when this [__]
happens it's like holy [__] I've been a
big Eminem fan for a long time I've been
listening to a lot to Logic for quite
some time now too before that uh and uh
but I mean and Eminem song for like 20
years so when when he posted the the
Tweet when he tweeted about me
that was really cool he tweeted about my
impression but then when you put it at
the end of The Thing it's just kind of
[__] crazy to me man like uh
it's just so weird
it's a trip it's cool it's awesome uh
and that's all I really have to say
about it because
you know
I you know the to to even I I know you
guys want me to talk about this is why
I'm talking about it but it's very cool
party wants to play it cool and be like
yeah you know it's like rolling this is
together but it's like it's [__]
it's you know it's very cool uh and it's
it's cool to see like I mean this [__]
is worldwide like people from Germany
are like I just found out who this
comedian is
uh that does an impression of Eminem
right
uh
uh here's an American comedian there was
this other guy that was doing a a
[__] um
reaction video I don't get reaction
videos on I guess it's just like a
a thing on YouTube but they're like
there was one guy that was like
reacting off of my video
or off of my Impressions on Eminem
Impressions and it was so funny dude the
guy was just like
he kept on being like all right man he's
on to something man he's on to something
Eminem he's on see I'm saying that [__]
the Eminem rap [__] that don't rhyme
um
there's reaction videos
the song now has 11 million views on uh
on the uh what do you call it uh YouTube
and then I posted way too many napkins
as a comment and it has nine thousand
likes and then I look at all but you
know what the dorkiest [__] is reading
that's the guy
I'm gonna play a little bit of that
reading the reading the comments on the
the YouTube
the song the YouTube oh my god dude
oh my God maybe I know what it's like
now for people who [__] come across
babies that are like doing my language
and [__] or people are like what the
[__] are these lunatics doing which I
appreciate I love because you're gonna
help us build the [__] Log Cabin
um
uh
uh look at look at I'm just gonna read
some of these [__]
this is just so funny to me
police questions me
cops how can you identify Eminem me he
doesn't breathe
ah it's all about
Eminem and logic drops homicide entire
Mumble RAP Community ah [__] here we go
again
look at this these guys aren't humans no
oxygen needed just throwing fire
look at this logic raps fast Eminem hold
my oxygen
it's so
dorky but love them
uh oh my God people cutting down trees
was never really the problem it was
logic and Eminem rapping together ah
because they take all that on here we go
Ariana Grande
Seven Rings logic and Eminem seven lungs
so how fast it
look at this plot twist Eminem is
logic's father
a what
plot twist on a song
like it's Game of Thrones
wow
um
look at it here's another one
all right
logic Eminem we have broke the internet
Mumble rappers what it cost logic Eminem
oxygen what
dude
and
that's so funny this guy what's it
what's the guide what's this video here
what is the guy
uh uh
reacting
I guess this guy's pretty popular
um here this guy it's even a little
penis the meanest thing this guy no life
Shack his name is so this guy
is just great let's check this out
y'all know we we react to Comedy a
little bit on this channel so this will
fit right in and it's very relevant to
what's going on okay right now so we're
gonna check this out I actually want to
see him do the impersonations like
I don't want to hear the Audio I want to
see him doing it let's get it
and he's starting it off with Eminem
rapper huh
of course I'm wrong torrent I'm watching
in the divorce
that's exactly how Eminem raps bro he'll
start out for something go away left
field you'll forget what he started with
and then he'll come back and stumbling
around with what he started with that's
exactly how Eminem rap was bro
he he bends and follows words to make it
fit in his rhyme scheme bro and that's
exactly what he was doing I mean I'm
doing it
you know and then he's just telling
people I'm doing it and this has a
hundred thousand views this guy this guy
this guy kind of kills it huh this guy
kills it this guy's [__]
he's kind of he's watchable though for
sure
um
anyway [__] that's been my world for
the week
um it's been very cool
uh
uh it's just cool when people [__]
kinda
appreciate what you do you know what I
mean